boys that he's really capable of playing
but in the beginning I wouldn't be
surprised if if he's suffering because
of lack of practice I mean I played
yesterday my my tournament my experience
myself against how in in the global
championship and the first two games you
know I played like a completely idiot
you know I I really felt like okay this
is a photo shame total degradation I
mean is this me you know I mean if if I
would be commenting my games I would be
saying that no no how can somebody play
like this I mean every movie is wrong
yeah and then you know after losing
these two games terribly I told myself
okay no come on if I if I already give
my name I'm playing I have to you know
no matter what I mean I have to try to
show my best and then I bounce back in
the third game thanks to to how also
because he was giving me a chance to to
play a game with the black pieces I won
a wonderful game and then in the fourth
game I played the Kingston attack with
white first time in my life I was
actually playing a wonderful game I was
I was winning but run out of time there
was only two seconds in